au coeur de l'été une nouvelle guerre du
caucase commence après plus de dix ans
passés à couvrir la région je me dis
qu'il faut partir le plus vite possible
allez en géorgie un pays occupé par
l'armée russe depuis 48 heures
le seul moyen pour me rendre la route
celle qui passe par l'arménie
potage voilà là c'est la frontière
arménienne
la géorgie est juste derrière ces
montagnes
soulagement après des rumeurs de
fermeture la frontière est toujours
ouverte
j'aperçois les premiers réfugiés ils
sont plus de 100 milles à fuir la guerre
c'est interdit de filmer ici
impossible
mais il est possible
de l'autre côté si l'on ferme
de billy si la capitale géorgienne est à
deux heures de route
nous traversons la ville et prenons la
route des combats les russes sont à
moins de 70 km après l attaque
géorgienne le 7 août sur l'ossétie du
sud une région séparatiste pro russe
moscou a envoyé plus de vingt mille
soldats dans la région
on est de la presse française
ça
ils disent que c'est dangereux
bouger à partir d'ici qui ne répondent
plus de notre sécurité
à peine franchi le barrage de la police
géorgienne une scène de panique au bord
de la route
il faut qu'on se dépêche qu'est-ce qui
se passe
les russes arrivent là les russes
arrivent là on doit y aller
une colonne de blindés russes approche
nous sommes à moins de 40 km de tbilissi
c'est horrible
il ya des morts partout dans les
villages ni partout
tout le monde à
laisser les enfants monte d'abord
il va bien bbc ce but
dépêchez vous les russes sont juste
derrière vite
il y a ceux qui parviennent à fuir
et les autres tous les autres années
nous sommes dits nous s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
nous décidons de reprendre la route une
route totalement déserte
quelques centaines de mètres plus loin
je découvre la colonne de blindés qui
avance vers la capitale géorgienne une
progression surprise que dément le
kremlin moscou est censé retirer ses
troupes selon un accord de paix signé la
veille les soldats tiennent un tout
autre discours
vous allez où on va lever ici vous venez
d'où on vient de se tenir et vous allez
où on va de billy si on ne l'invité
en étant le territoire russe
la russie a décidé de mettre au pas la
géorgie un pays indépendant depuis la
chute de l'urss qui a choisi depuis cinq
ans l'allié américain
on reste en code président le veut et il
a dit quoi votre président
il nous a dit de rester jusqu'à ce que
les géorgiens se rendent
j'ai foutu devrait pas dire ces choses
là qu'est ce que vous faites là
on est là pour une mission de paix pour
défendre les civils
mais la géorgie est un pays indépendant
mais les géorgiens ont bombardé le ceti
désormais sacré des femmes et des
enfants alors
[Musique]
c'est une vengeance alors
on est là pour qu'il ne recommence plus
on leur donnait une leçon
ce jour là les russes vont étendre la
zone d'occupation de plus de 30
kilomètres à l'intérieur des terres
géorgienne plus loin des blindés nous
empêche de passer un général russe
confirme à la presse étrangère que
prendre la capitale géorgienne n'est pas
exclue
vous êtes prêts à vous battre contre les
géorgiens sûrement le groupe n'exclut
rien sur moi on est prêt
titouan américain peut prendre bagdad
pourquoi les russes ne pouvait pas
prendre bbc
nous décidons de suivre la colonne qui
continue son avancée imperturbable vers
la capitale géorgienne
gueorgui mon chauffeur géorgien craint
désormais le pire
bastia
j'ai peur qu'on ne puisse plus les
arrêter
on va les dépasser à les voir plus loin
là où l armée géorgienne
si les russes vont jusqu'à eux je ne
sais pas ce qui peut arriver
plus loin l'armée géorgienne se prépare
les russes sont à 2 km
la plupart de ces sommes viennent juste
d'être rapatriés de bagdad où ils
étaient 2000 à se battre aux côtés des
américains
une armée géorgienne équipée par les
etats-unis- leur matériel et flambant
neuf ils ont interdiction de nous parler
hors caméra ils me disent ne pas croire
à un affrontement direct
derrière les lignes géorgienne je
découvre des réfugiés après examen on a
besoin d'un bus pour aller à tbilissi on
peux pas vous aider on doit sécuriser la
route
ça fait 15 jours qu'on marche quatre
jours qu'on fume pas mais personne ne
défend personne j'ai perdu tous mes
enfants fuyant je ne sais pas où ils
sont
c'est atroce on nous a abandonnés dans
les villages dès que tu sors la tête on
te tue il n'y a personne pour enterrer
les cadavres ils sont dans les jardins
parterre
venir en gt les hlm les a mais vous ne
pouvez pas défendre tous ces civils qui
sont coincés dans les villages
comment voulez vous qu'on fasse il y a
cinq cents ans dans la zone occupée ça
sans encre us je ne peux rien faire nous
respectons le cessez-le-feu et où il
avance
une armée géorgienne impuissante des
civils livrés à eux mêmes
je laisse ces femmes en me disant qu'il
faut tenter d'aller dans la zone occupée
le lendemain matin je reprends la route
à 35 km de tbilissi un barrage et or
vient aujourd'hui on ne passe pas plus
loin les policiers sont nerveux
je vais vite comprendre pourquoi c'est
ici que les rues sont d'installer leur
poste de contrôle
l'armée russe et cette fois ci aux
portes de la capitale géorgienne
on ne va pas c'est aujourd'hui
la ya un tank russe derrière ils
n'étaient pas là hier
ça c'était hier
je peux aller les voir oui allez-y
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ici selon l'accord
de cessez le feu il devrait se retirer
du rgi pas avancer allez donc leur
demander nous on comprend plus rien
bonjour on est des télévisions
françaises on peut vous parler
il est où le commandant
ces soldats sont arrivés dans la nuit
ils viennent du quartier général de
l'armée russe à grozny la capitale
tchétchène
je met du temps à les convaincre de nous
parler le fait d'avoir souvent été en
tchétchénie et de connaître les villages
où ils ont combattu me permets peu à peu
d'installer un dialogue
pourquoi pensez que vous êtes en géorgie
c'est quoi votre mission on est là pour
une mission de paix pacifier la région
hier le président bush a dit que l'armée
russe devait quitter tout de suite le
sol géorgien vous en pensez quoi
on en a rien à faire de ce que dit bush
c'est pas notre président c'est sûr
c'est pas lui qu'on me paye et il le
sait très bien
on s'en fiche de ce qu'il dit ce qu'on
veut à l'image
mais vous êtes sur un territoire
étranger ça vous fait quoi
c'est perdu hier on s'est perdus
la russie c'est par là non vers
billysiens
des soldats convaincu que la géorgie est
encore leur chasse gardée quoi qu'en
pensent les américains
finalement le régiment de grozny nous
laisse passer plus loin nous entrons
dans la zone occupée
la première chose que je remarque c'est
deux soldats un peu à l'écart qui
attachent à leur bras des brassards
blanc c'est quoi ce brassard ça veut
dire quoi
on fait ça pour reconnaître qui est de
l'autre côté qui est russe
ouais c'est ça
se reconnaître entre russes pourtant
juste à côté je revois la même scène
cette fois-ci ce sont des hommes en
civil qui porte le brassard blanc
ce sont des paramilitaires eaux cette
ces hommes sont accusés d'exactions
depuis plus d'une semaine dans les
villages géorgiens passer son contrôle
russe sur une zone de plus de 20 km une
fois que les chars russes sont passés
ces miliciens sèmeraient la terreur sans
que les militaires russes ne réagisse
à deux mètres du barrage j'observe un
étrange manège
je vois un milicien détacher sa plaque
d'immatriculation sous les yeux des
soldats russes
l'absence de plaque permet aux milices
d'opérer dans les villages géorgiens en
toute impunité j'arrive à parler à l'un
d'entre eux
nous ont bombardés et nous on les a
dégagées de notre terre
il ya beaucoup de morts
nous on est venu se venger
et ici vous fait roi on continue
d'avancer on va les pénétrer par le feu
jusqu'à bbc
que se passe-t-il derrière les lignes
russes que font ces miliciens pendant
une demi heure j'assiste à un ballet
incessant de voitures aux sept cents
plaques qui reviennent des villages
géorgiens ici c'est eux qui règne en
maître et il n'aime pas les témoins
[Applaudissements]
nous le comprenons vite
là
toi range ta caméra les militants
veulent savoir qui nous sommes ils sont
surtout intéressés par nos 4 4 l'un
d'entre eux montent dans une de nos
voitures il met en joue notre chauffeur
géorgien pendant de longues minutes nous
avons craint le pire un officier
supérieur russe finira par intervenir il
nous conseille de partir au plus vite il
ne peut plus assurer notre sécurité
nous décidons de passer par une autre
route en espérant ne pas recroiser les
milices ossètes nous rentrons dans la
zone occupée je constate l'ampleur des
destructions des kilomètres de forêts de
champs incendié par l'armée russe nous
arrivons enfin à gorron la ville
géorgienne passé sous contrôle russe
depuis une semaine
bonjour on et de la télévision française
gori ville bombardée villes occupées
ville coupée du reste du monde
aujourd'hui une semaine après les
bombardements russes au milieu des
ruines je ne croise que des ongs
le silence et puis soudain des cris un
peu plus loin je vois une foule à
famille c'est la première distribution
de l'aide alimentaire pour les quelques
centaines d'habitants qui n'ont pas
réussi à fuir la ville
d'homs et à moi mais t'es foutu la
féconder
de moine bouteilles d'huile mes enfants
meurent de faim tu le sais bien sa c 4
jours qu'on n'a pas mangé
des jours entiers sans rien on va faire
quoi prendre les armes pour avoir du fun
laquelle
pourquoi le gouvernement ne fait rien il
n'y a plus d'autorité voilà quoi on en
est réduit à
l'arraché jeu les volets je ramène tout
chez moi
une émeute de la faim sous les yeux de
staline qui est né dans cette ville
la situation est pire encore dans les
villages alentour une zone interdite
livré au règne des milices ossètes les
premiers convois vers les villages sont
organisés aveu d'impuissance les
autorités de la ville sont obligés de
demander à l'occupant russe d'assurer la
sécurité les bus peuvent être attaquées
à tout instant par les miliciens
je parviens à convaincre un soldat russe
de nous laisser monter la condition ne
pas filmer son visage il fini par me
dire il faut que le monde sache ce qu'il
se passe là bas
nous sommes les premiers à entrer dans
le no man's land des villages pillés par
les miliciens depuis une semaine sur
plus de 20 kilomètres la zone occupée
ressemble à une zone morte
premier village tri avis on m'a dit
qu'ici les raids des milices avaient été
particulièrement meurtrier
je me suis sauvé
mon village est en feu
et ont brûlé ma maison
et s'il vous plaît aidez-moi
aidez-moi
mon fils est resté bloqué là-bas c'est à
plus de 10 km je dois absolument aller
voir
la maison a été complètement détruite
le village pillés
je ne sais pas si mon fils est en vie je
ne sais pas ce qu'il reste de mon
village
je ne sais rien
suite du programme sacha nous emmène à
une grande manifestation de soutien à la
russie
vous avez 30 minutes ok vous pouvez
aller où vous voulez parler à qui vous
voulez
à la tribune le président ossète edouard
kokoïty réclame l'indépendance de
l'ossétie du sud et revendiquent la
protection du grand frère russe
le monde va devoir compter avec la
russie et nous sommes avec elle
le caucase et russes
et nous ne donnerons jamais le caucase
des irresponsables comme israël
saakachvili le président géorgien et à
l'américaine condoleezza rice
ils n'auront pas notre terre ils n'ont
rien à faire ici
dans la foule des cris de colère de
haine une haine qui manque une haine
interethnique ranimer pour longtemps par
ses journaux de guerre
c'est normal on est brûlé et pillé leur
maison
les géorgiens nous ont agressés alors on
ne s'est pas gênée on leur a fait payer
chaque goutte de sang versée
mais comment vous allez vivre ensemble
dans le futur je ne sais pas toute façon
c'est plus possible
alors c'est la xoom s'il faut se battre
on se battra
et la russie défendra toujours
l'ossétie du sud une terre nettoyer une
terre passer sous la protection russe
[Musique]
pour les hommes du régiment de grozny
mission accomplie leur campagne de
géorgie s'achève
alors vous rentrez à la maison ouais
c'est super
darmon whaou à la maison
enfin cette sale guerre est finie réchy
la coque speck chi minh ville la russie
est comme un nourrisson dort mais
si on la réveille elle est de très
mauvaise humeur
la russie il ne faut pas la taquiner la
chatouiller
la russie est forte et nous on l'a
montré
les troupes russes s'éloigne pour
combien de temps
mon voyage en géorgie se termine je ne
peux m'empêcher de penser que je vais
revenir bientôt
sur les braises du caucase une nouvelle
guerre froide est en train de s'écrire
[Musique]